where's my gwen bring me my sticks
this the [ __ ] do sticks you took them
from the table
hello everybody it is me elise and today
i am only going to be eating food emojis
that's it that's the video there's like
50 something different food related
emojis
i have them all listed right here this
thing
is going to randomly choose i think i'm
gonna do two
i don't know if you could see but i just
click on this button called random
choice
and it'll pull up a random thing so the
first thing
that i'm going to have for breakfast
is drumroll
[Music]
fly flan
and the second option shall be
what is that soup oh it's fondue
so for breakfast i'm making flan and
fondue
double f all right so i started off by
heating some sugar on a pan
and mixing it to turn it into some
caramel and then i poured it
into these little glass ramekins and
swirled it around all nice
yes and then for the mixture i just
combined some eggs
evaporated milk vanilla extract some
condensed milk which is sold
mix that all up together poured it into
the glass ramekins and then
baked it while it was baking it was time
to make the fondue
so i just shredded up a bunch of cheese
mozzarella
cheddar gouda and then i poured some
wine
into my pot and then just added the
cheese slowly and kept mixing and then
it was
it was exactly what it needed to be and
then i just had some broccoli
some wheat bread and some apples to dip
and my beautiful flan and that's it my
very nutritious
breakfast of fondue and
flan first of all let's try and tip this
flan over
let's give it a couple pats ah
huh i don't know 100 what i did wrong
for it to kind of come out all
slot side lopsided like this but
i did my best the fondue however
looks delectable oh glorious
[Music]
you know what they say a well-balanced
breakfast is not complete without
eggs and there's eggs in this flan so
technically
this is exactly what i'm supposed to eat
it tastes good it just
doesn't look as good i tried my best
all right i won't lie breakfast was a
little bit strange
my stomach is doing you know some weird
stuff with all that dairy i just put in
my body
so for lunch i shall be having
oh ah spaghetti like white spaghetti
plain spaghetti wheat spaghetti
spaghetti
my other lunch dish will be this is uh
hanami dango the the little red white
and green
um mochi balls on the stick okay
i can do that i mix together sweet rice
flour sugar and water until it's the
consistency of cookie dough
for the green one i used some matcha and
roll it all up and for the pink one i
just used some red food coloring
and then i boiled them and after a
little while i put them in an
ice bath and then put them on the stick
and look at them yeah
of course in my house we have so much
pasta but no
pasta sauce i expect nothing less from
my family so
i'm gonna make it from scratch pasta
sauce is pasta sauce very easy you know
onions garlic tomato sauce a bunch of
seasonings
mix it all up it's all good and then i
plated it with my
various colored pasta noodles because
that's all i had
and i put the sauce on top and yeah
lunch time
okay so i have my pasta here and i know
that
this isn't a perfect recreation because
i have so many different colored pasta
noodles on my plate
but you know what we don't segregate in
this house and we support
all pasta noodles i have my hanami dango
here
and i put it on this little toothpick to
be as
accurate as possible now this looks
exactly like the emoji okay you can't
tell me that i didn't do that this one
was so easy
all right let's get a taste of this
pasta
[Music]
it's good i don't play with pasta i love
carbs
all right y'all we're in the final
stretch i changed my shirt because it
smells like
tomatoes it's time for dinner for dinner
we have
not the hello
i don't want to make this what is this a
raspberry cake that's not even
let's get a second option and our other
option
a chicken drumstick i guess for dinner
i'm having
a cake a raspberry cake and a chicken
drumstick
all right so first i struggle to open
the packaging but once i got that
open i cracked some eggs add in some
milk
mix it all up together and then i poured
it into some cake tins that i will later
realize were too small
but i baked them and i guess they
overflowed and i burnt them at the
bottom but it was fine because they came
out
nice so i made some cream cheese
frosting and i cut off the
tops of the cake and put the icing on it
as filling for some reason i'm deciding
to make this a triple layered cake
and then i decided to aggressively crumb
coat it
and i don't know how to do this so i
just it wasn't working out
and so i just decided to get some
fondant because you know
you know what cake boss said when in
doubt
fondant out i'm pretty sure he didn't
say this but either way it was pretty
simple from there and then i just glued
on the raspberries and now it's time for
the chicken i put a bunch of seasonings
some mustard pickled juice mixed it all
up and then i let it sit in the fridge
for 30 minutes
just coated it in some flour and
breadcrumbs friday and yeah there it is
all right sean be honest what do you
think about my masterful dinner here
ten out of ten don't lie the chicken
looks good this cake is pitiful okay
this cake about ugly as hell but guess
what
listen we're gonna take it for what it
is not what it could have been
i'm not i've never been good at um
confection
we need the candles and we're going to
be celebrating
the end of this video and the fact that
i've just eaten
the most insane food combinations today
because of emojis i know my cake isn't
nearly as cute as the emoji one
but it's not horrible
i already know the chicken about to be
busted i'll go ahead and take a bite
[Music]
the chicken is absolutely scrumptious
and i knew it would be the emoji was
just brown so i didn't know if i should
bake the chicken or fry it but i decided
to fry it
because i felt like that was more
authentic i got here
my knife i don't eat cake and i don't
like raspberries but
i'm still gonna slice this what i think
about it i don't even think the cake
emoji was a three-layer cake but of
course you know me
had to go all out check me out check me
out i'm not even mad at it
all right i know y'all just heard me say
i don't eat cake but i'ma eat this
just for the sake of the video
oh well i'm not a fan of raspberries but
this isn't horrible like i just had a
weird-ass diet today i won't even lie
but most of the food was good i think i
liked the fondue and the chicken the
most
a weird challenge but i didn't hate it
i'll see you guys in the next one
[Music]
bye